Shure: OK我给拔了我给他插上
Shure: OK, I unplugged it and plugged it back in.
Shure: OK所以我现在可以去做咖啡了吗杨老板
Shure: OK, so can I make coffee now, Jake?
Shure: 好的
Shure: Alright.
Nicous: 现在是派厅
Nicous: Now it's the dispatch hall.
Jake:多亏了你们
Jake: Thanks to you guys.
Jake:哈哈哈我等了两天
Jake: Haha, I waited for two days.
Jake:我操走散完全了
Jake: Damn, everything fell apart.
Jake:我操这之前都是就是只能开个眼镜
Jake: Damn, before this, I could only crack open my eyes.
Jake:然后现在我很怕
Jake: And now I'm really scared.
Jake:等我半点下睡觉
Jake: Let me sleep for a bit.
Katrina: 再说要哭了
Katrina: You're about to cry again.
Jake:哎这个这个
Nicous: 哈哈哈你他妈
Nicous: Haha, you damn...
Shure: 你们在干嘛
Shure: What are you guys doing?
Shure: 做咖啡
Shure: Making coffee.
Katrina: 咱真的跳这么难的吗
Katrina: Are we really dancing something this hard?
Katrina: 我有跳过
Katrina: I've danced before.
Katrina: 但是他们有两个没跳过舞的
Katrina: But there are two who haven't danced before.
Katrina: 他这动作还挺碎的
Katrina: His moves are quite delicate.
Katrina:  挺快的
Katrina: Pretty fast.
Alice:是不是一点难了
Alice: Is it a bit hard?
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
Katrina: 那么咱就跳这
Katrina: Then let's just dance this.
Katrina: 有事有活干了
Katrina: We have things to do.
Katrina: 我说要学这个舞的话这两天有活干
Katrina: If we learn this dance, we'll have something to do for the next two days.
Jake:对对上去因为上面有内个就是有线数据
Jake: Yeah, yeah, go up, because there's a data cable up there.
Katrina: 这也大家一起看
Katrina: Everyone's watching this together.
Katrina: 真的吗这么厉害
Katrina: Really, this impressive?
Katrina: 分解教学
Katrina: Step-by-step teaching.
Shure: 呃15克的豆子240克的水
Shure: Uh, 15 grams of beans, 240 grams of water.
Shure: 240克对
Shure: 240 grams, right.
Katrina: 学吧来吧挑战
Katrina: Learn it, come on, challenge.
Shure: 我刚想说手术到级结果多了0.3颗
Shure: I was just thinking about the operation level, and it turned out to be 0.3 grams more.
Shure: 问题不大然后剩下就等他
Shure: Not a big deal, then just wait for it.
Shure: 等等他滤一
Shure: Wait for it to filter.
Shure: 般都是1:15 啊
Shure: Usually it's 1:15.
Shure: 1:16吧好像是
Shure: 1:16, I think.
Nicous: 我擦这种这么办啊
Nicous: Damn, what do we do with this?
Shure: 这不能对
Shure: This can't be right.
Shure: 他不是不是浓缩的才可以对
Shure: It’s not correct unless it's concentrated.
Katrina: 一起吧一起学吧
Katrina: Let's learn together.
Alice:我不会
Katrina: 我我也没学过这舞试一下
Katrina: I haven't learned this dance either, let's give it a try.
Katrina: 试一下吧
Katrina: Let's try it.
Alice:我敢想象我跳这个会有多么的扭曲
Alice: I can imagine how twisted I would look doing this dance.
Shure: 是的这都是浅红的豆子
Shure: Yes, these are all light red beans.
Shure: 然后所以就果香会多一些
Shure: So, they have more fruity aroma.
Shure: 果香花香
Shure: Fruity and floral.
Shure: 像那个咖啡店那种
Shure: Like those coffee shops.
Shure: 直接做美式的Espresso
Shure: They make Americanos with Espresso.
Shure: 那种都是深红的
Shure: Those are all dark red.
Shure: 就是它基本只剩苦味了
Shure: They basically only have bitterness left.
Shure: 是它就是Espresso加水就叫
Shure: It's just Espresso with water added.
Shure: 浓缩就是咖啡机弄出来的
Shure: Espresso is made by the coffee machine.
Shure: 大概这么一勺子的
Shure: About a spoonful.
Shure: 就类似于你喝酒那勺子杯
Shure: Like a shot of alcohol.
Shure: 一勺子的咖啡液对
Shure: A spoonful of coffee liquid, yes.
Shure: 就是演演示一下磨成粉
Shure: Let's demonstrate grinding it into powder.
Shure: 然后放到一个这么样的
Shure: Then put it in a...
Shure: 一个一个粉碗里
Shure: A powder bowl.
Shure: 然后给他压成饼然后上到机器上
Shure: Press it into a puck and place it in the machine.
Shure: 然后他开始压出来那么一点浓缩液
Shure: Then it starts extracting a bit of concentrated liquid.
Shure: 可以了再画呵呵
Shure: Okay, let's draw again, haha.
Katrina: 你们泡的是哪个呀
Katrina: Which one are you brewing?
Katrina: 泡那个云南那个吗
Katrina: The one from Yunnan?
Shure: 来来来尝尝
Shure: Come, come, taste it.
Katrina: 云南那个很酸
Katrina: The Yunnan one is very sour.
Shure: 我自己手冲的尝一口
Shure: I made it myself, have a sip.
Katrina: 早上那个云南的也很酸
Katrina: The Yunnan one this morning was also very sour.
Katrina: 怎么首充
Katrina: How to brew it?
Katrina: 就是你把它倒了
Katrina: Just pour it in?
Katrina: 这张倒
Katrina: Pour it in?
Shure: 不是什么叫倒
Shure: No, what do you mean pour?
Katrina: 哈哈哈我以为是你
Katrina: Hahaha, I thought you meant...
Shure: 你在说什么
Shure: What are you talking about?
Shure: 拿这个就那么那么那么一点点浇上去
Shure: Just pour a little bit like this.
Shure: 就这种
Shure: Like this.
Katrina: 哦懂了
Katrina: Oh, got it.
Katrina: 感觉得灌很多牛奶啊
Katrina: Feels like it needs a lot of milk.
Shure: 我哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 咖啡豆后天到
Shure: The coffee beans will arrive the day after tomorrow.
Shure: 这个确实有点太酸了
Shure: This one is indeed a bit too sour.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 可以你可以感觉一下这个感觉
Shure: You can feel this sensation.
Shure: 味道其实差不多
Shure: The taste is actually similar.
Shure: 会比刚才淡一些
Shure: It's a bit lighter than before.
Shure: 这个把这个绿纸拿
Shure: Take this green paper.
Shure: 哎呦呦呦他在低
Shure: Oh, it's getting lower.
Shure: 不可以不是没没有这么喝的
Shure: No, you can't drink it like that.
Shure: 就跟你泡茶倒茶台
Shure: It's like when you brew tea at the tea table.
Shure: 茶台里的
Shure: On the tea table.
Katrina: 我们这里有
Katrina: We have it here.
Katrina: 我们镜子太小了
Katrina: Our mirror is too small.
Alice:微微你醒了吗
Alice: Tasha, are you awake?
Shure: 真的要吗
Shure: Do you really want it?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: 呃脏倒是应该不脏
Shure: Uh, it shouldn't be dirty.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:你要打开门吗
Alice: Do you want to open the door?
Shure: 呃也不是
Shure: Uh, not really.
Shure: 就跟那个是一样的
Shure: It's just the same.
Alice:我要进来吗
Alice:哎呀我进不来
Alice: Oh no, I can't get in.
Shure: 就是240克
Shure: It's exactly 240 grams.
Alice:算了
Shure: 官方建议然后对
Shure: The official recommendation, right.
Alice:哎呀我这眼睛是有路的
Alice: Oh, I can see the way.
Shure: 大多数都是
Shure: Most of them are.
Alice:出来吧
Alice: Come out then.
Lucia: 刚站在这里看还没有看出来
Lucia: I didn't notice when I was standing here.
Alice:那我先给你关上吧
Alice: Let me close it for you.
Shure: 忘给
Shure: Forgot to give.
Shure: 后天我的咖啡豆就到了就可以
Shure: My coffee beans will arrive the day after tomorrow, then it's fine.
Alice:哎呀,算了
Katrina: 真的要跳
Katrina: Do you really want to jump?
Lucia: 我这边反光刚好
Lucia: There's a reflection here.
Lucia: 打在打在这个人上看不清楚
Lucia: It's shining on this person, can't see clearly.
Alice:要不要把那个窗帘放下来,或者
Katrina: 他手啊什么动作
Katrina: His hand movement.
Lucia: 或者我们现在需要用到这个这个灯吗
Lucia: Or do we need to use this light now?
Lucia: 这样可能会好一点
Lucia: Maybe this will be better.
Katrina: 天呐我们像练习室啊
Katrina: Oh my, we look like we're in a practice room.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 我们前面应该还有一个大镜子
Lucia: We should have a big mirror in front of us.
Lucia: 就更好了
Lucia: That would be even better.
Lucia: 这样就能
Lucia: Then we could...
Katrina: 你看他还挺快的
Katrina: Look, he's pretty fast.
Lucia: 哦可以可以
Lucia: Oh, okay, okay.
Lucia: 那个那个那个影楼灯
Lucia: That, that, that studio light.
Lucia: 那个柔光板一定要加上
Lucia: We must add the soft light panel.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 这动作感觉好陌生
Lucia: This move feels so unfamiliar.
Katrina: 是所以我在想要跳这个吗
Katrina: Yeah, so I'm wondering if we should dance to this?
Katrina: 我怕对他们太难了
Katrina: I'm afraid it's too difficult for them.
Shure: 我们跳queencap吧
Shure: Let's dance to "Queencap".
Lucia: 你可以看着跳吗
Lucia: Can you watch and dance?
Shure: 如果我们看电影是在楼上看是吗
Shure: If we watch a movie, do we watch it upstairs?
Shure: 比如说想要看看个电影什么的
Shure: Like, if we want to watch a movie or something.
Katrina: 可以吃火锅的时候
Katrina: While eating hotpot.
Shure: 集体观影
Shure: Watch it together.
Lucia: 我们可以把它投到这个上面吗
Lucia: Can we project it onto this?
Lucia: 把这个视频
Lucia: This video.
Shure: 对可以可以
Shure: Yeah, we can, we can.
Shure: 好像也行
Shure: Seems possible.
Lucia: 这样是不是方便学一些
Lucia: Wouldn't that make it easier to learn?
Lucia: 因为只要这个灯打开
Lucia: Because as long as this light is on.
Lucia: 就是它屏幕上就会有一个亮点
Lucia: There will be a bright spot on the screen.
Katrina: 然后我有点反光
Katrina: Then I get some glare.
Lucia: 然后我有点散光
Lucia: Then I get some astigmatism.
Choiszt: 可以啊可以
Choiszt: Yeah, it's possible.
Lucia: 所以所以我看动作有点看不清楚
Lucia: So, so I can't see the moves clearly.
Katrina: 所以我看那个
Katrina: So I see that...
Jake:投过了投过了
Katrina: 偶买噶出道了哈哈
Katrina: Oh my god, we're debuting, haha.
Lucia: 但有个问题是我们好像只能投5次
Lucia: But there's a problem, we can only project it 5 times.
Lucia: 是不是应该把这个宝贵的机会啊
Lucia: Should we save this precious opportunity...
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure: 这小米这个可以那什么
Shure: This Xiaomi can, you know...
Shure: 我来解决一下
Shure: I'll handle it.
Katrina: 咱应该是只跳了1分 1分40
Katrina: We should've only danced for 1 minute and 40 seconds.
Katrina: 应该只跳了1分30
Katrina: I think we only danced for 1 minute and 30 seconds.
Katrina: 差不多吧
Katrina: Pretty much, right?
Katrina: 再再看一遍
Katrina: Let's watch it again.
Shure: 我感觉你好像长高了
Shure: I feel like you've gotten taller.
Katrina: 这
Katrina: This...
Shure: 他怎么又变成这个德行了
Shure: Why is he acting like this again?
Shure: 好像那个送孩子来上跳舞课
Shure: It's like when you send your kid to dance class.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 然后在后面等着
Shure: And then you wait in the back.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 像吗
Shure: Right?
Lucia: 我要换双鞋子
Lucia: I need to change my shoes.
Lucia: 不行这个这个
Lucia: This pair isn't working.
Lucia: 等一下我如果戴着眼镜进去
Lucia: Wait, if I wear glasses inside...
Lucia: 是不是他就拍到我
Lucia: Will he film me?
Lucia: 乱七八糟的箱子
Lucia: The messy box.
Katrina: 没事我已经拍过很多遍
Katrina: It's fine, I've filmed it many times already.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Katrina: 差不多学到这
Katrina: That's about it for learning.
Katrina: 差不多我觉得已经很很多
Katrina: I think we've done quite a bit already.
Katrina: 没有只学了一分半看那个
Katrina: We didn't just learn for 1 minute and a half, look at that.
Katrina: 要不直接一起跟着学
Katrina: How about we all learn together?
Shure: 早上好夜之城
Shure: Good morning, Night City.
Katrina: 我也要换血
Katrina: I need to change my blood too.
Katrina: 穿拖鞋带裤
Katrina: Wearing slippers and pants.
Shure: 昨天的死人乐透
Shure: Yesterday's dead lotto.
Katrina: 确定学这个了吗
Katrina: Are we sure we're learning this?
Katrina: 有有意义吗
Katrina: Is this meaningful?
Katrina: 感觉这个有一点点小难
Katrina: I feel like this is a bit tough.
Katrina: 但是只要大家有决心
Katrina: But as long as everyone is determined.
Katrina: 就肯定能有学会
Katrina: We'll definitely learn it.
Shure: 你怎么还PUA我们呢
Shure: Why are you PUA-ing us?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 其实还有一个
Katrina: Actually there's one more thing.
Katrina: 你今天看群里了吗
Katrina: Did you check the group today?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 稍微再低一点头
Shure: Lower your head a bit.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 好他现在不动了
Shure: Okay, he stopped moving now.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina: 这可能会学的比较有成就感
Katrina: This might make learning feel more rewarding.
Lucia: 拖鞋都快让我跳的甩出去了
Lucia: My slippers are almost flying off from all the jumping.
Lucia: 换一个跟脚一点
Lucia: Let's change to something more secure.
Lucia: 这我能看清
Lucia: I can see this clearly.
Lucia: 这个腿要换吗不用换
Lucia: Do we need to change legs? No, we don't.
Shure: 操我的
Shure: Damn, my bad.
Shure: 我的我的我的
Shure: My bad, my bad, my bad.
Shure: b站怎么不堪入目呢
Shure: Why is Bilibili so inappropriate sometimes?
Shure: 有点哈哈
Shure: It's kinda funny though.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 没办法
Shure: Can't help it.
Shure: 没没有关系
Shure: It's fine, no worries.
Shure: 你发我我直接点链接进去吧
Shure: Just send me the link directly.
Shure: 叫啥呀这个
Shure: What's it called?
Katrina: 练吗
Katrina: Practice?
Shure: 教那些小知识
Shure: Teach those little tips.
Lucia: 我觉得这个不错
Lucia: I think this one is good.
Katrina: 要不跳这个吧
Katrina: How about we dance to this one?
Lucia: 因为他的动作重复
Lucia: Because the moves are repetitive.
Shure: 他叫什么
Shure: What's it called?
Lucia: 重复率很高
Lucia: The repetition rate is high.
Shure: 他叫什么这个
Shure: What's it called?
Katrina: 偶像万万岁
Katrina: Idol Glory.
Shure: 偶像
Shure: Idol.
Katrina: 你要跳那个吗
Katrina: Do you want to dance to that one?
Katrina: 投票吧
Katrina: Let's vote.
Katrina: 不是这个版本
Katrina: Not this version.
Katrina: 这是原男团版本
Katrina: This is the original boy band version.
Lucia: 什么刚那个是原版吗哈哈
Lucia: Was that just now the original version? Haha
Lucia: 掉针了
Lucia: Dropped a stitch.
Lucia: 哈太难
Lucia: Haha, too difficult.
Katrina: 真的
Katrina: Really.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure: 七彩阳光吗这不
Shure: Isn't this like "Sunshine Rainbow"?
Shure: 广场舞级别
Shure: Square dance level.
Shure: 这个我要Queen cat
Shure: I want to do Queen cat.
Katrina: 决定一下吧
Katrina: Make a decision.
Katrina: 今天下午讨论一下
Katrina: Let's discuss this afternoon.
Alice:还有分成
Alice: And also the division.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Katrina: 爱心
Katrina: Love.
Lucia: 这次就爱心了
Lucia: This time it's all about love.
Lucia: 真的很难说短剧和这个谁尬哈
Lucia: It's really hard to say which is more awkward, the short drama or this.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Shure: 说实话跳这个是态度不行
Shure: To be honest, if you dance like this, the attitude is not right.
Shure: 跳yes OK
Shure: Dancing yes, okay.
Shure: 是能力不行
Shure: The ability is not there.
Shure: 我们先拿这个热身好吧
Shure: Let's warm up with this first, okay?
Katrina: 好的看来你们还是想学那个是吧
Katrina: Alright, it looks like you still want to learn that, right?
Shure: 哎呀操哈哈
Shure: Oh my god, haha
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Katrina: 这个有3分钟
Katrina: This one is 3 minutes.
Katrina: 那个是只跳1分钟
Katrina: That one is just 1 minute of dancing.
Lucia: 哎可以跑起骚瑞我的错我的错
Lucia: Oh, you can start running, sorry, my bad, my bad.
Shure: 万万岁
Shure: Long live.
Katrina: 课间操没这么短哈哈哈哈
Katrina: The recess exercise isn't this short, hahaha.
Lucia: 不是怎么回事
Lucia: What's going on?
Lucia: 为什么又开始跑步
Lucia: Why are we running again?
Katrina: 啊有点累
Katrina: Ah, a bit tired.
Lucia: 这运动量其实也不小呢
Lucia: The amount of exercise is actually not small.
Alice:哎哎哎
Alice: Eh, eh, eh.
Katrina:  太简单了
Katrina: Too easy.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:就学完了是吧
Jake: So, are we done learning?
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Lucia: 他们已经这个顺利学会了
Lucia: They've already successfully learned this.
Shure: 觉得这个没有难度
Shure: I think this is not challenging.
Shure: 我们需要学学有一点东西的东西
Shure: We need to learn something with a bit more substance.
Shure: 哎我的b站又烂掉了
Shure: Oh no, my Bilibili is acting up again.
Alice:来吧
Lucia: 不如我们跳worth it这个我也复习起来能快一点
Lucia: How about we try "Worth It"? I can review it quickly.
Jake:再看一下
Jake: Let's check it out again.
Katrina: worth it的感觉是很早很早前的舞了
Katrina: "Worth It" feels like an old dance.
Shure: 呦
Shure: Oh.
Katrina: 高中的时候就跳
Katrina: We danced it in high school.
Shure: 你还没有开
Shure: You haven't turned it on.
Lucia: 对对我那会大一的时候跳的
Lucia: Yeah, I danced it in my freshman year of college.
Jake:你没开
Jake: You didn't turn it on.
Shure: 你先把这退出一遍
Shure: Try exiting and re-entering.
Lucia: 所以其实也忘得差不多了
Lucia: So I've forgotten most of it.
Shure: 让再进去
Shure: Then go back in.
Lucia: 但是比学个新的能快一点
Lucia: But it's still faster than learning a new one.
Jake:那一会再看一次
Jake: Let's watch it again later.
Katrina: 所以
Katrina: So...
Katrina: 呃我想想本来备选还有什么来着
Katrina: Uh, let me think, what were the backup options?
Katrina: 奔跑的青春和
Katrina: "Running Youth" and...
Lucia: 哎奔跑青春可以让他们去跳那个solo
Lucia: Hey, "Running Youth" can have them do the solo.
Choiszt: 再跳我要解除封印了
Choiszt: If I dance again, I'm going to unleash my power.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:啊你要干嘛了
Jake: Ah, what are you going to do?
Shure: 要脱光膀子了是吧啊
Shure: Are you going to strip down?
Katrina: 那就跳这个黑色的
Katrina: Then let's dance to this black one.
Katrina: 哎为什么声音这么小
Katrina: Hey, why is the sound so low?
Jake:声音可以弄大一点
Jake: We can turn up the volume.
Katrina: 我我已经调到最大了
Katrina: I've already set it to the maximum.
Katrina: 对这是教学
Katrina: Yeah, this is the tutorial.
Katrina: 真假哈哈惊呆了
Katrina: For real, haha, I'm shocked.
Shure: 哎呀卧槽
Shure: Oh my god.
Jake:好了哦行
Jake: Alright, okay.
Shure: 太sex了吧这个
Shure: This is too sexy.
Katrina: 这正常的绝世元素
Katrina: It's a normal element of the dance.
Jake:来也跳啊
Jake: Come on, let's dance.
Jake:你们跳一跳
Jake: You guys, give it a try.
Alice:来吧
Katrina: 5 5678
Katrina: 5, 5678.
Lucia: 哎怎么又校准一次
Lucia: Hey, why did it calibrate again?
Jake:因为刚刚有没有开
Jake: Because it wasn't turned on earlier.
Katrina: 刚开始是背过去的23456
Katrina: At the beginning, it's facing backward, 23456.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Katrina: 5678
Lucia: 原来如此
Lucia: I see
Katrina: 33456784234
Alice:把这个往后推一推
Alice: Push this back a bit
Shure: 哪一部我不会了
Shure: Which part? I don't know how to do it
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 等一下这个是
Lucia: Wait a minute, this is
Katrina: 你不是要跳
Katrina: Weren't you going to dance?
Shure: 买喽买喽买喽
Shure: Buy it, buy it, buy it
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:我问你没开
Jake: I asked if you turned it on
Jake:你没电了吗看一下
Jake: Are you out of battery? Check it
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Jake:right
Jake: Right
Jake:对这是一个15156
Jake: Yes, this is a 15156
Shure: 行了这
Shure: That's it
Katrina: music
Katrina: Music
Shure: 太简单了太简单了
Shure: Too easy, too easy
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 1234567822345678323456784234567耶
Shure: 1234567822345678323456784234567 yeah
Shure: 洒洒水
Shure: Piece of cake
Katrina: 一辈子
Katrina: For a lifetime
Shure: 三四五六七八二二三四五
Shure: Three four five six seven eight two two three four five
Shure: 六七八三二三四五
Shure: Six seven eight three two three four five
Shure: 六七八四二三四跑
Shure: Six seven eight four two three four run
Shure: yes OK
Shure: Yes OK
Shure: 二三四五六七八二二三四五
Shure: Two three four five six seven eight two two three four five
Shure: 六七八三二三四顶
Shure: Six seven eight three two three four top
Shure: 二四二三四
Shure: Two four two three four
Lucia: 我们已经自动有了代教老师了
Lucia: We automatically have a substitute teacher now
Katrina: 再跳舞是吗
Katrina: Dance again, right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahaha
Shure: 一二三四
Shure: One two three four
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Shure: 是不是武士就是都是这个样子
Shure: Aren't warriors all like this?
Katrina: 突然把屁股顶了出去
Katrina: Suddenly sticking out the butt
Shure: 哎呦1234
Shure: Oh wow 1234
Shure: 56
Shure: 5678
Shure: 12345678